[Music]
we just had Hollywood Super Bowl I'm
Lauren C and I'm doing direct oh thank
you for joining us for our live recap of
the 90th Academy Awards so we got a
launch right into the big winners of the
night but of course we want to know what
you guys thought did you agree with the
top winners what were your favorite
moments of the show we're gonna run down
everything that was huge that happened
no mistake on the best picture announced
so please leave your comments of course
we'll get them here in et's iPad so
let's talk best picture right off the
bat we just heard it a shape of water
congratulations with the shades of water
it was the film that earned the most
Oscar nominations this year with 13 if
you guys watched our preview on Friday
we talked about how the Best Picture
race was probably the most wide open
it's been a long time we predicted that
the shape of water would take it and in
fact did which was really exciting
because if you guys watched it guillermo
del toro just gave a really passionate
an emotional speech really dedicated to
young filmmakers out there who are
watching and I thought it was so
poignant and he made that moment just to
share share about his journey there he
talked about how Steven Spielberg
inspired him and told him hey just know
that when you're up there you are part
of a lineage of amazing talented
filmmakers so it was a really special
time nicely putting things into
perspective on the 90th Academy Awards
Guillermo was up on stage a couple times
tonight he also talked about the
importance of you know acknowledging
immigrants and the contributions they've
made to our countries so many immigrants
in the room him gal gadot so many a lot
guys but also a nod to gear Mo's sense
of humor I loved that when he got up
there for Best Picture he opened that
envelope handed to by Warren Beatty and
he double checked it and he said it yes
yes it was shape of water there was no
mistakes guy there's no Best Picture
flub you knew we knew that was not gonna
fly again but yeah I got I can also see
a Warren Beatty and Faye Dunaway's faces
open envelope they were visibly nervous
they're like let's get it right
understandably that led to such a
conversation that they weren't really
asking for last year and
that the show did such a great job
including Jimmy Kimmel of nodding to it
he said it's the 51st anniversary of
Bonnie and Clyde which is why we have
Warren Beatty and Faye Dunaway up here
again so they really did a great job
even before the announcement they cut to
a shot of the envelope and said everyone
this is the envelope that will contain
the best picture announced and right
before that Jimmy was like nothing could
go wrong from here yeah and like you
said best picture shape of water we had
kind of predicted that and again many of
the categories you guys we told you
there weren't gonna be a lot of major
upsets that was our guess and we were
right there were tons of major upsets so
best actor went to Gary Oldman he was
the favorite to win for the darkest hour
and he won that's his first Oscar so
yeah good moment exactly a memorable
moment but we have to talk about Frances
McDormand who took home her second Oscar
for Best Actress I mean we kind of
anticipated that she was gonna give a
speech that was either very impassioned
very hilarious probably both it was
obvious yeah there's also really special
yeah let's talk about it guys because
Frances McDorman has been wowing us and
surprising us with her speeches all
Awards season long she got up there
tonight and she said I have something to
say and she did so friend gets up there
and she did something really powerful
what she asked was that all of the
female nominees in the audience stand up
she even joked she said maril well if
you go first everybody will and Meryl
didn't and it was a powerful moment all
the female nominees in the room got
applause and Frances said hey here's the
thing we want this to go beyond tonight
also have these women meet with you in
your office and there's finance their
projects and it was such a powerful
moment Jimmy Kimmel said she should win
an Emmy for that speech the only thing
that did make me a little sad though is
there weren't that many women that got
the chance to stand up is it that
incredible there weren't that many
scenes yeah it's kind of insane but I
will say what a selfless moment for the
obviously she's just won an Academy
Award her second what not many people
can say that but she actually made it
more than her right yeah more than her
and honestly it was a moment for all
those women the audience to celebrate
each other you could see them all just
looking at each other Margot Robbie was
getting emotional I think they were all
excited to not only share in that but
also be like we are about to also make a
powerful state
in that moment just by standing up all
females you know of course in light of
all the sexual harassment allegations
that has been plaguing Hollywood all
Awards he's along it was a really really
poignant moment and times up in me to
those movements were a part of the
conversation tonight we'll talk about
that also want to clarify something for
you guys if you were a little confused
or wondering what it meant
Francis ended her speech by saying she
had two words for everybody inclusion
writer so in an inclusion writer what
that is is basically just the idea that
if you want to hire an actor or actress
or somebody to work in your movie on
your project that you have to promise to
be inclusive in your hiring of other
people in the movie of other women of
people of color of people of different
sexual orientations so she was saying
make that inclusion Rider something that
you do in your work because that's the
thing is that change has to start with
people helping people people hiring the
right people and making the change come
from tiny steps that make for big moment
it was amazing that that message was
coming from her you know what I mean
like she's been very vocal all season
long yeah and like we listen and like
you mentioned at the top of her speech
she was like I have something to say and
she said that she did all right so who
won Best Supporting Actor well that went
to Sam Rockwell with read billboards uh
her co-star of course that was really
sweet to his thinking his wife he was
thinking Frances he was really excited
to to win that award and obviously he
was the first one to kick off the whole
show so that was exciting but also we
got to give a shout out to Allison
Janney who also want her first Oscar for
Best Supporting Actress for I Tonya I
love her I love her so much
well she's not too much I mean queen of
the Emmys is not clean of the Oscars I
love it I have a feeling we're gonna see
her up there one more time I'm calling
it right now but she did go up there and
the first thing she said she jokes I did
this all by myself of course was kidding
right was kidding but one of the
speeches to thank the people to God she
got her way she was so excited we
actually caught up with her on the red
carpet right before the award show and
she mentioned how what she was gonna do
she almost decided she wasn't gonna do
act anymore she said she wasn't pursue
it and here's how she overcame it here's
what she told et's Kevin Frazier and
Nancy O'Dell well I've had many dark
times so I thought about giving up
acting
and the way I got through it was right
before I was going to pick another
career or fly home to Dayton Ohio I
would get a job something would come
through at the last minute it was I you
know I did a lot of research to find out
what else I could do if I wasn't an
actress
and it always seemed like when I got to
that most desperate point I would just
get a little nibble like something would
come and that never led her to an Oscar
everybody take a bite out of that out
yes aren't you glad she didn't quit
because it's the hardest job in the
world I always think of that Amy Poehler
quote she said if you can see yourself
doing anything else
don't be an actor because it's the
hardest job it involves so much
rejection and so much striving for
yourself I shouldn't say the hardest job
but it's a tough job and you're really
putting yourself on the line so it was
great to see so much great work
celebrated tonight and you guys as
comments are coming in Jacy picks shape
of water to win so we had some fans out
there
hope you won your Oscar pull JC okay
Sonny didn't do that didn't do that okay
I also didn't do that bad Lauren I
didn't do that bad and win but I didn't
do that bad I didn't even fill one out
so Who am I to talk I'll wanted three
billboards to win we got those acting
wins for it though not Best Picture
Little Miss over on YouTube says Francis
is amazing yes she is
also loved how she acknowledged her
family in the audience ooh and you
really see people's like true emotions
when they get up there and she said this
feels like I'm I'm Chloe came at the
Olympics winning and Laura loved the
performance of this is me yes so many
people were like emotionally overwhelmed
she was into that she's yeah and into it
you mentioned how hard it is to be an
actor and you know this people certainly
have two-pound payment and someone who
knows that all too well actually is
Jordan Peele who tonight became the
first african-american to win Best
Original Screenplay for get out one of
the most powerful and socially relevant
films of the year I actually lost my
pool because I voted get out for Best
Picture as much as I loved shape of
water and as much as I appreciate Garen
was working that film oh well I can do
it that's why it's so fun when Best
Picture is this wide open is because you
have these surprise wins especially
after get out and get out one of the
indie Spirit Awards literally yesterday
people were like oh that's usually into
best picture but so awesome to see
Jordan Peele becoming the first
african-american man to win for Best
Original Screenplay I felt like that was
a moment where you just saw the raw
emotion of this guy kind of being like I
was this comedian and now I have an
Oscar you seen his face he tweeted after
he's like there's some expletive so I
will repeat it but he is shocked that he
won an Oscar he is shocked he won an
Oscar but also I will say I probably got
the most thunderous and rousing applause
he got a standing ovation when he won
and like you mentioned when he's walking
away I think he was so nervous he forgot
in a khole Kidman was behind them oh my
god just like finished his speeches like
I can't believe I just wanted Oscar so
that was cool to watch this guy from
Comedy Central just make it on the
Academy Award stage absolutely
so speaking of you know we're talking
these emotional moments these raw
moments that really got to all of us so
let's just talk the biggest moments of
the show Jimmy Kimmel opened I want you
to talk about that a little bit because
guys I was on the red carpet so I miss
the Elvis got back you know he had a lot
to address you know obviously he went
for Harvey Weinstein he went for it you
know he also was he found that balance
like we predicted of being political and
being poignant but also funny ah but I
will say uh if I'm being honest I feel
like his monologue was a little less
memorable than it was last year yeah III
think so he was trying to move it along
and I will say though the funniest
moment came perhaps of him bribing the
entire audience saying guys this is a
long show yeah apparently the first
Academy Awards only 15 minutes so to
bribe them the incentive was if you gave
the shortest acceptance speech you
walked home with a jet ski folks and
what to present the Jeske none other
than I love it and by the way he came
true on that promise at the end somebody
want to believe it was a win for costume
and Helen Mirren was riding the jet ski
with the winner look at her she's like
price is right like Vanna whiting that
it was really really funny she changed
her gown from the red carpet just for
the poor she did that Dame Helen Mirren
that's the queen she says I saw her on
the red carpet she was any blue dress
she had blue stunning jewels you guys go
check out the photos at ET online.com
she told me they were Harry Winston
jewels she said it's the first time she
were serious jewelry so she had to wear
a simple dress but now we know she also
had to have a fun
sexy dress on during the show helen
mirren checks all our boxes for prices
right mama
yes eldest should I do anything oh my
gosh so many great women and by the way
you guys so many female presenters
tonight that was something that the
Academy did consciously as part of the
movements that were happening all Awards
season long at the Golden Globes
everybody wore black that was not the
case at the Oscars tonight because the
leaders of times up said look we don't
want to be anti awards show and we don't
want to detract from the show we're just
about making the movement and longevity
of it so but ways that they did nod to
the movements that were happening were
all of the female presenters so let's
talk about a lot of them is my spirit
animal Rita Moreno first of all she is
rocking the same dress she wore in 1962
and she won an Oscar for a West Side
Story and look at her she on the moment
you guys that was just her interest and
we play it again Rita just loving that
relishing it three oh my god that's a
viral moment you know what week the
Oscars sometimes could be a three-hour
DAP you know but no people like Rita
really liven it up and it was so fun to
watch and then I want to get into tell
me pure comedy pure comedy gold
Tiffany Haddish and Maya Rudolph you
guys if you miss this we are only able
to show you a little bit of it but it
was like they were up on stage
presenting a couple of awards for
several minutes we were laughing our
butts off we want to give you a little
bit taste a little taste of what they
did they were playing off of you know
the former hashtag Oscar so white which
Oscars have got a little less white but
not that much less white so here are
Tiffany in Maya but we when we came out
together we know some of you were
thinking are the Oscars too black
but we just want to say don't worry
there are so many more white people to
come to
so yes tell me that was not an audition
to host the Oscars for next year I
literally was I mean what we want is for
them to host the Oscars by the way you
guys Katy Perry tweeted Rudolph Haddish
20/20 she wants them to run for
president say if they're not gonna host
the Oscars maybe they can run for office
I just loved them they were so funny
Tiffany by the way out there and up in
hugs because they were joking that they
just wanted to go out there take their
shoes off their feet hurt and I don't
know if you guys noticed that white
dress she's wearing is the same one she
wore during the girls trip premiere and
when she hosted us and I she said I
bought this dress with my own money and
I'm gonna get a lot of use out of it yes
and that she did Tiffany I mean what
we've witnessed since girls trip came
out is a woman who was working hard in
this industry and is now just bursting
onto the scene and she used every moment
of the Oscars to become unforgettable
not just on the show but also on the red
carpet I mean she really did own her
moment she is beside herself that she
has had the year that she's had but that
she's also at the Academy Awards an e
t--'s Kevin Frazier got the best
reaction from her about being there but
also being called out by Beyonce in her
new song are you going to her party
tonight they're having a party talk
about anything you see the party nothing
else at the party nothing I feel like
tiffany has learned her lesson she met
Beyonce at a after-party for jay-z's
concerts not to selfie with her and then
she was blabbing a lot about that
needed' and she claimed that Beyonce
wanted to fight another woman who came
to talk to jay-z all of a sudden top off
with dj khaled came and Beyonce sing
about Tiffany and non-disclosures I'll
tell you wait TIFF he's about to turn up
at that party but we're never gonna know
about it we're never gonna know about it
and you know what I support Tiffany in
that because she gets to have a
friendship with Beyonce and but I love
first of all love the Beyonce called her
out and that Tiffany's like yes this is
the coolest thing ever that Beyonce
called me up talk about a positive spin
I agree Katy Perry had ash for president
she put that political positivity spin
on everything I'm moving right along you
know another bit
Jimmy had told us that he was hoping
that after the Oscars he did something
that people would be talking about the
next day I think his attempt was this
sketch where he basically pulled stars
from the Oscars audience and brought
them in to a secret screening next door
at the Chinese Theatre of a wrinkle in
time and surprised the audience the best
part about it though was you have all of
these Oscar nominees all these
celebrities and these stars walking in
with like movie theaters maybe bookmarks
no I think it was like a 6-foot saw just
like that
ah to hand out to the audience and then
you had army hammer and Ansel Elgort
with legitimate hotdogs would you call
it a hot dog cannon how can it shoot all
dogs at the audience like you imagine
just sitting there watching Oprah in a
wrinkle in time I was saying Jimmy
Kimmel walks in with Armie Hammer oh
[ __ ] it was super fun and I think you
mentioned this earlier with the
monologue the thing is Jimmy Kimmel has
got himself to go up against when he's
hosting you know so we remembered of
course there that great moment where
they brought a tour group into the
Oscars before and we had those people
like oh my god I'm at the Oscars he kind
of reversed engineered it this year and
had the actors go to the regular people
I mean it's kind of you mentioned it but
it is a tough task to follow yourself I
mean this is a second time back to back
you know so how do you outdo yourself
and especially after that Best Picture
fiasco as a mess as it was it was such
good TV those accidental
moments they make for such great TV that
then the Academy's got to find a way to
make great TV in a planned way and it's
hard you can't create something to go
viral like scripting it you know it's
already do you tried it it was good it
was overall say this I'm here for Jimmy
Kimmel of course yes I need to be
further a lot of serious topics that he
also had to like address right I mean
they had to be they fold it into the
show I know you have some long time jobs
yeah guys I mean again like we said
times up did not want the whole night to
be about the movement women were wearing
times up pins on the carpet but they
didn't want to acknowledge it and they
had said there would be moments
acknowledging it during the show so
there was we got just different
interviews with different actors talking
about you know making changes in the
industry and what they wanted to see
happen from here actors and actresses
talking about not only you know being
inclusive to women but also being
inclusive to different religions and
races and we also had an awesome
performance that brought out some of
those faces of the different movements
on stage so that was a little taste of
it we'll have more for you guys at ETA
online.com but I actually got to speak
to Ashley Judd and Mira Sorvino on the
red carpet so they showed up together
and they were two of some of the first
women to come forward talking about the
allegations of sexual harassment they
had that had happened to them so I
talked to them about what it was like
frankly that Harvey Weinstein was not at
the Academy Awards tonight because that
man was a face on those red carpets for
years with winning movies winning Oscars
himself so here's what Ashley and Mira
had to say
it feels appropriate and as Mira said
sexual abuse and sexual trauma are
really hallmarks of American culture and
so we're here to change that and to have
a full revolution and it's just
wonderful to get to be a part of in some
small and very significant ways so she
was just so poised and speaking so
perfectly and I think that was hard for
them you saw and when they were on stage
tonight you know these are really raw
things that have happened to these women
and for them to power through and to be
on that red carpet doing interview after
interview and to then get up on stage I
was just so impressed with them we
mentioned on Friday that Ava Duvernay
had revealed that the time's up members
had actually met with show producers to
carve out a moment obviously it's really
hard to ignore what's going on in
Hollywood right now so it was kind of
amazing to see that they did really
address it directly and but also in such
a poignant way but that being said you
know it wasn't just that either the
women's movement I felt like this Oscars
in particular was probably one of the
more most important ones one of the more
important ones and as we saw with the
winners a lot of inclusion a lot of
diversity
you saw Mexico really represented today
with our tonight with Guillermo del
Toro's win and shape of water Coco
Jordan Peele became the first African
American screenwriter it was just a
really poignant poignant ceremony yeah
would you agree Oh a hundred percent and
so great that it was the 90th Academy
Awards you know the Golden Globes had an
anniversary this year as well so it was
great that it all started there and now
we're wrapping this awards season up
with this really powerful night and it
does also put into perspective how long
it's taken change to happen in that
package I think it was Geena Davis she
said you know when Thelma and Louise
came out people thought oh this is gonna
be the watershed moment and that was
decades ago so here we are now still
pushing for that change to happen but I
think what's awesome to see is how
everybody embraced that tonight and how
everybody was taking a moment to make a
difference with what they Edison pops
the production because they also
addressed it in those mashup montages
like I'm thinking about Best Supporting
Actress in particular they matched of
all the past winners from their films
and made a really powerful statement it
was kind of amazing to watch I was yeah
with the sound bites they use they made
a statement with them it was really
great
you guys are probably gonna win an Emmy
really special night and wanna get some
more of you guys's comments Simone since
she was so excited for Jordan Peele Kat
says Rita is a legend yes she is
a lot of you guys are talking about how
much you loved mary j blige as
performance is amazing oh my god she had
told me around a January at the
beginning of this long hall of award
shows that she was dieting for this girl
go get yourself a double-double get your
cheeseburger at that Governor's Ball you
deserved it double nominee also made
history tonight I thought all of the
performances tonight we're really really
solid yeah and of course you guys we
want to remind you we are just giving
you a taste Oscars they just finished
we're still processing them and we love
hearing all of your thoughts so please
keep sharing them with us and head over
to eat see online comm where we
literally have an office full of people
breaking out every interview we're doing
talking about all the different moments
and getting all that great content for
you and you can still get your oscars
fixed tomorrow we are breaking down the
fashion of the night the most talked
about moments what you didn't see on TV
that will be live tomorrow morning at
11:30 a.m. Pacific we're doing a live
version of the daily Denny so make sure
you check us out on et's facebook page
also our youtube channel may I tease
that one woman I spoke to was wearing
four million dollars worth of diamonds
you guys you're gonna have to find out
who was tomorrow and of course check out
Entertainment Tonight tomorrow night
because eat see the show we'll have all
these great behind-the-scenes moments
that you didn't see on TV and the
parties the parties are still to come
right now we're gonna be up for a while
thank you so much for following along
and watching and of course head over ét
online.com for all things Academy Awards
thanks for a great award season you guys
i'm lauren zima
that's right i'm duty director goodnight
[Music]
you
[Music]